[Musique]
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
vincent chauvet vous êtes le maire modem
de la commune d'autant en saône-et-loire
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous à vos
côtés jacques myard mer les républicains
de maisons laffitte dans les yvelines
bonsoir jacques myard à vous aussi merci
d'être là le patron du modem 1 françois
virot qui dit retire donc est la
sonnette d'alarmé il réclame un pacte
national pour la démographie pour sauver
le modèle social selon lui il manque 40
à 50 mille naissances par an deux
solutions soir les français doit faire
plus d'enfants soit accueillir des
personnes d'autres pays est ce que vous
partagez le constat de votre patron
vincent chauvet oui alors le surveillait
loup qui est actuellement au commissaire
au plan il fait un constat qui est très
clair c'est que on a une démographie qui
est en train de stagner avec un risque
de diminution de la population française
et que cette diminution de la population
ne serait pas compatible avec notre
système sociaux et pose un certain
nombre de problèmes qui le détail très
clairement notamment en terme de
puissance pour pour notre pays et donc
la ville
il fait une tautologie c'est assez
évident il ya deux solutions plus
d'enfants ou plus de personnes de
l'extérieur et là dessus nous devons
avoir effectivement une nouvelle vision
retrouver une politique nataliste une
politique familiale plus forte a été un
peu mis en cause ces dernières années
par un certain nombre de gouvernements
précédents notamment au niveau fiscal et
on se rend compte qu'en ce moment il ya
quand même avec la crise économique le
coc vide une peur et un risque que ce
nombre d'enfants diminue encore et donc
il faut retrouver les moyens pour les
familles de pouvoir faire des enfants
et puis ensuite en fonction de ce nombre
d'enfants des malheureusement toujours
en dessous du seuil de renouvellement de
2,1 enfants par femme est bien avoir des
arrivées de populations d'autres pays
qui puisse compenser qu'on arrive à
garder un
niveau au moins stable de populations
parce que ce qui menace notre pays c'est
bien la dépopulation jacques myard c'est
assez destructif comme une idée en ce
moment alors que beaucoup des lieux
appelle plutôt à stopper l immigration
verra tout à l'heure ce qu'en pensent
les français
françois bayrou lui souhaite ouvrir
davantage peut-être les vannes pour
régler notre problème démographique vous
êtes d'accord avec lui premièrement il
pose le problème en terme théorique et
de ce côté là c'est clair soit on
renouvelle nos populations par une
politique nataliste soit effectivement
il y aura un appel de l'extérieur donc
sur ce plan là c'est vrai mais
aujourd'hui personne ne peut dire
premièrement pourquoi il ya une baisse
de natalité bas c'est la politique
désastreuse qui a été conduite par les
deux gouvernements
l'actuel et le précédent qui ont taillé
dans les dents des allocations
familiales des classes moyennes c'est
lamentable lamentable et au jeu c'est
par exemple pierre dumont a parfaitement
démontré pierre gérard dumont que dès
que l'on touche à la politique nataliste
on a une baisse effectivement d'enfants
et il nous manque aujourd'hui environ 70
milles en vente et donc il faut quand
même insisté sur ce point c'est que
c'est une politique délibérée
idéologique qui a été conduite par
hollande et qui a été poursuivi par
macro c'est ça la réalité est donc
effectivement berrou constate une chose
évidente
maintenant il faut bien savoir une chose
il ya toujours eu des gens qu'ils ont
voulu venir en france
et personne ne les empêchera il ya
toujours eu un certain nombre
d'intégrations le problème je vous fait
rire
comment faites-vous la mayonnaise la
mayonnaise vous l'a fait quand vous avez
d'abord beaucoup d'ingrédients et que
petit à petit vous rajoutez l'huile
c'est à dire l'apport extérieur de
population vous devez le faire par dose
est donc en posant le problème tel qu'il
a été posé par bo
il ya un côté de provocation évident qui
n'est pas acceptable parce qu'on sait
bien qu'il ne suffit pas de faire venir
des gens pour qu'ils soient intégrés
c'est toute une politique et c'est une
question le quantitatif pose un problème
qualitatif
donc il faut regarder les choses telles
qu'elles sont il faut rétablir une
politique nataliste en faveur des
familles françaises
c'est évident chose qui pour l'instant
n'a pas été fait et qu'il appartient au
gouvernement de faire je dirais une
politique à 180 degrés par rapport à ce
qui la conduit aujourd'hui
et lorsque l'on accueille un certain
nombre de personnes de l'étranger
il faut vérifier s'ils ont toutes les
capacités à s'intégrer c'est aussi comme
ça je voudrais dire une chose c'est que
dans les années 20 nous avons eu
certains disent sans problème religieux
et bien méfiez vous parce que dans les
enlèvements nous avons eu beaucoup de
polonais qui sont venus en france
ça s'est mal passé ça s'est mal passé
notamment dans le nord de la france et
donc un certain nombre se sont
parfaitement intégrés
d'autres sont repartis donc il n'y a pas
dans ce domaine là je dirais de vérité
absolue
ce qui est certain c'est qu'il faut que
les français fassent eux mêmes leurs
propres enfants
avant d'aller chercher à l'extérieur
parce que ça se passe pas toujours très
bien
alors vincent chauvet un chiffre à vous
donner avant de répondre à chaque
milliard
regardez ce sondage ifop 71% des
français qui estiment que notre pays
compte déjà beaucoup d'étrangers et
quelques uns des immigrés
supplémentaires rien n'est pas
souhaitable 7 points par rapport tout
même à 2018 c'est amélie qu'il faut
prendre en compte c'est vrai que ce que
vient de nous dire jacques myard voilà
c'est ça interroge c'est ce qu'on entend
sont beaucoup voilà de deux plateaux
télé aujourd'hui d'articles de presse de
radio ce problème d'intégration est ce
que ça ne va pas rajouter un problème un
problème selon vous est-ce qu'il faut
écouter ce sondage et ces français qui
sont mais j'étais rencontre est-ce que
je pense qu'il faut faire
est ce que suggère françois bayrou c'est
justement un débat sur l'immigration et
on est en train d'avoir et moi je suis
assez d'accord même entièrement d'accord
est ce que vient de dire jacques myard
d'une part
il faut une politique nataliste qui ne
se confondent pas avec une politique de
redistribution
c'est ce qui est écrit dans la note de
françois bayrou c'est à dire que on est
des aides aux familles et que ce ne soit
pas un moyen de compenser des inégalités
de salaires égalité de richesse c'est
l'erreur en fait qui a été fait par les
gouvernements précédents et qui nous
amène aujourd'hui au fait que certaines
familles de la classe moyenne ne sont
plus soutenues pour faire des enfants
c'est assez clair et là dessus le
diagnostic je pense est partagé et puis
l'autre aspect c'est de dire
effectivement des apports extérieurs
ça doit se faire comme le dit d'ailleurs
françois bayrou dans le maintien de la
cohésion nationale que c'est pas
uniquement une question de deux pays
d'origines de cultures d'origine mais
aussi de capacité de d'accueil
d'absorption d'intégration dans des
petites villes on peut accueillir
peut-être certains réfugiés on peut
peut-être accueillir et d'ailleurs on le
fait à autun on peut peut-être
accueillir d'autres populations du bord
on qu'elles sont bien encadrés avec
choisi notre émigration vincent chauvet
clairement favoriser la migration
il faut à la fois choisir l'immigration
on va avoir besoin d'un de main d'oeuvre
aussi dans certains secteurs de manière
énorme notre vieillissement
démographique qui est aussi une des
causes de la baisse démographique
implique énormément de demande de main
d'oeuvre dans le secteur des services à
la personne qu'on n'est pas capable de
courir aujourd'hui donc il va bien
falloir qu'on trouve des personnes pour
s'occuper de nos anciens donc il faut le
choisir
et puis il faut choisir aussi les lieux
d'implantation il ya peut-être des
endroits des quartiers où comme le dit
votre sondage il n'est pas souhaitable
qu'il y ait davantage de population qui
ne sont pas encore intégrés en revanche
dans d'autres endroits dans des villages
dans le morvan
on peut peut-être faire faire cet effort
on le voit d'ailleurs dans des affaires
c'est médiatique d' apprenti boulanger
qui se sont intégrés qui veulent
travailler avec des pétitions
c'est le cas à autun avec un jeune
c'était qu'un besançon il ya quelques
mois avec des pétitions de de tous les
habitants pour garder des jeunes qui ont
trouvé un métier et qui se sont insérés
dans la lah
le tissu économique donc ce débat je
pense qu'on peut le faire la voir sur
des bases concrètes et raisonnables et
de savoir voilà quand il manque autour
de 50 mille naissances par an pour
assurer le renouvellement des
générations
ces cinquante mille personnes il faut
bien que si on veut que notre pays se
maintiennent il faut bien les trouver il
faut voir comment elles viennent est ce
qu'il ya une politique de solidarité
internationale par rapport à des
minorités opprimées des chrétiens
d'orient ou autres escales des minorités
intra européenne ou des populations
intra européennes qui peuvent venir ça
on ne maîtrise pas dans l'espace
européen on ne maîtrise pas assez des
questions qui sont très problématiques
beaucoup de jeunes d'europe de l'est
sparte ça déstabilise l'europe de l'est
arrive en europe de l'ouest ça peut
déstabiliser aussi certaines certaines
régions quand il ya des influx qui ne
sont pas forcément encadré ou contrôler
et puis d'arriver à trouver cet
équilibre est d'avoir ce débat pour
trouver le nombre de personnes qui
doivent venir en faisant par exemple il
faut des étudiants et là il faut le
maximum d'étudiants étrangers qui
viennent apprendre qu'ils viennent
s'enrichir en france et ensuite qu'ils
peuvent travailler il faut une part de
solidarité est à voir sur débat pour
savoir combien de personnes on est prêt
à accueillir où on est prêt à
l'accueillir et de quel type
ces personnes doivent venir pour
correspondre à l'économie et à la
société française
henri jacques myard blé goudé c'est
assez simple je crois que en ayant mis
en parallèle politique nataliste et
appel à l'immigration c'est une faute
politique
aujourd'hui c'est une faute politique et
ça agite je dirai tout un tas de choses
pas acceptable il s'agit de faire tout
capoter
il est exact que la france a toujours
intégré un certain nombre de gens qui
venaient d'ailleurs et on ne peut pas
généraliser c'est du cas par cas ou
presque
mais ce qui est certain c'est qu'il faut
poser ap initiaux les critères
d'intégration
quand j'entends sur les affaires des
étudiants dont acte on forme des
étudiants étrangers
et ceci alors que normalement les formes
pour qu'ils retournent dans leur pays
pour aider leur pays à décoller il reste
la plupart du temps en france et là
c'est une aberration c'est aller à
l'encontre des pays d'origine et pour
nous effectivement il y a
deux personnes qui intègrent des gens
qui ont été par la france
mais ce qui est clair c'est que il faut
d'abord remettre en place une politique
nataliste forte c'est jouable
si vous voulez le problème des retraites
ce pas le problème des retraites à
points
présenté par ce gouvernement c'est une
escroquerie intellectuelle
le problème des retraites c'est combien
de gens qui travaillent combien des gens
qui sont à la retraite
donc il n'ya qu'une solution c'est la
reprise de la natalité et cette
politique effectivement et ça a été dit
par mon collègue et à qu'on a confondu
politique sociale et politique nataliste
dans tous les partis 1
parce que moi j'ai entendu un certain
nombre de mes amis politiques dire mais
moi si j'ai trente quarante mille euros
de revenus par mois
je n'ai pas besoin des allocations
filiale familiale faux faux archi faux
parce que sa compagne sa femme elle veut
être reconnu en tant que tel
lorsqu'elle porte un enfant et qu'elle
le met au monde donc c'est une erreur
tragique qui a eu lieu par les
gouvernements successifs
ça a commencé avec hollande ça s'est
poursuivi avec mâcon et au passage
chéramy bo ou aujourd'hui tu y mets un
coup de pied dans la fourmilière et la
politique gouvernementale
je ne sais pas comment le sparadrap de
l'elysée va s'en sortir
je le dis comme je le pense vincent
chauvet vous êtes d'accord avec ce
postulat on entendait aujourd'hui dans
la journée un yves d'amécourt par
exemple nous dire voilà pour sauver son
modèle social on doit retrouver la
politique familiale c'est ce que dit
jacques myard détruites paroles ont
soutenu par beyrouth et transformer nos
politiques publiques pour retrouver le
plein emploi vous êtes d'accord avec
cette petite pierre envoyé dans le
jardin de françois méro ce que dit mon
collègue est tout à fait il ya un
aveuglement fait générale de l'ensemble
des partis qui ont considéré
effectivement qu'on devait moduler les
allocations familiales en fonction des
revenus avec le le quotient familial etc
et que ça a été une erreur mais c'est
une erreur collective on va pas jeter la
pierre sur sarkozy hollande bayrou
macron ya une erreur collective de notre
pays on
et là aujourd'hui c'est un quotient
familial nicolas sarkozy aussi il ya eu
un certain nombre de pistes d'économies
qui ont été faits au détriment peut-être
des familles il ya aussi l'organisation
des crèches et aussi peut-être une
responsabilité de certains élus locaux
il ya une responsabilité on va dire
collective ça sert à rien de jeter la
pierre
mais ce que en revanche on peut avoir la
meilleure politique du monde c'est pas
pour ça
nécessairement que les gens donc se
mettre à faire plus enfance et des
mécanismes qui sont extrêmement
compliqué aujourd'hui la natalité baisse
partout en europe
partout en europe la france est encore
un peu sur le dessus et l'italie
l'allemagne l'espagne les pays latins
ont des taux de natalité qui sont
proches de 1,3 si jamais même en ayant à
la meilleure politique familiale la
meilleure politique nataliste du monde
on n'arrive pas à avoir un nombre
d'enfants qui nous permettent le
renouvellement des générations
mais à ce moment là c'est pas une faute
politique c'est l'évidence même il va
falloir se demander comment on fait pour
équilibrer notre population est donc un
débat à avoir sur l'immigration en
termes d'obligations et pas seulement en
terme de fantasmes ou de peur agité par
les en remercie le débat a débuté ce
soir en tout cas merci vincent chauvet
merci beaucoup à jacques myard hombourg
et invitera jacques myard jeunes vont
s'en inspirer comme d'ailleurs souvent
et se refait une politique de crèches à
mettre en oeuvre ce que nous faisons
dans notre ville parce que de ce côté là
il est très important que effectivement
les femmes puissent continuer à
travailler
ce que n'a pas fait l'allemagne ce que
n'a pas fait l'italie donc on avait une
politique de plein air le 1er juillet
pour inciter les pères à pour moi la
légalité qui laissera l'on doit faire
des zone euro prenne une politique
familiale et que les collectivités comme
la cale suivent à la condition qu'elles
en aient les moyens au maire de lézignan
est une catastrophe
merci beaucoup vincent chauvet jacques
myard d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur arte france